on this episode I go to floor 12 of
vaynermedia and I answer some questions
you ask questions and I answer them this
is the askgaryvee show
a lot of traffic coming good that's what
I want
let's go what's this no here we go
ninety-eight hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 98 of
the ask gary vee show you can walk
you guys aren't black and white right
now cuz that's how we edit alright let's
do this
that was good right Jose asks just
catching up to askgaryvee caches oxygen
episode 96 so what's the second product
team or service was a great question
your caches oxygen there is no second
right like that's like the
all-encompassing it's not that its first
but I think I think your real question
is really interesting because the fact
that matters there's a hundred different
things that could be it right you could
be amazing at growth hacking you might
have designed the greatest product the
truth is you know especially for me I
love to give like definitive answers to
get people moving because the more you
ponder the more you squander what and so
and so and so and so don't be crippled
by what is that other thing I think that
other thing could be the thing that
you're strong at and and we all have
those things for me it's sales right
like both businesses I built Wine
Library and now vaynermedia is
predicated on I'm extremely good at
growing the top-line revenue of the
businesses that I'm at the helm of later
on I work about driving profit backups
some people are efficient at the profits
in the beginning or architecting
business that's profitable from the get
or financial engineering or amazing
designers that are so overwhelming they
can't sell or build a business but they
bring in that skill later because the
quality of their art or product is so
incredible you might design an amazing
product and that might be at the core so
there's a lot of different things cash
though is oxygen
from Jack Henry I Jack Henry Jack -
Henry what Jack Henry asks what are the
biggest mistakes you see young
twenty-year-old entrepreneurs such as
myself making Jack Henry there are so
many damn mistakes you're making and you
youngsters that this actual show would
take the rest of my life have I just
decided to list them all on the flip
side there's so many incredible 21 year
old entrepreneurs I mean I don't want to
sit up here as the old do to me like you
kids you Millennials are doing all these
things wrong it you think I think
there's there's market conditions and I
think market conditions right now for
youngsters are not creating strong
disciplines in business it's so easy to
do a start-up it's so easy to raise
money that a lot of people are just not
uh you know when you're 21 year old and
literally the last even hardcore
economic issue was in 2008 geez you were
14 when that hit the fan
that's insane by the way to me number
two like you just have never lived it
it's always been good for you debt John
- Henry it's always been good for all
the 21-year olds it's always been what I
call peacetime generals and I think to
be a great business woman or man you
need to be a wartime general as well
talk to me you know it's gonna be fun
episode 697 of the askgaryvee show when
the stock market collapsed and when
money's not flowing and when there's
some geopolitical event that's changing
the landscape and not everybody's
writing a ho I should invest in next
Facebook and uber then entrepreneurs are
gonna really rise to the top that are
real ones not fake ones and I think I
think that not understanding the
principles of building teams building
good product knowing how to sell these
things that we have been thematic
through these hundred episodes that's
when they matter and so my friends if
you've been confused
let me unconvince not right now these
hundred episodes they're not about right
now they're about what's coming and
what's coming is bad times and good
times and in bad
and then good times and the bad times
stats say with me bad times bad time
then good times and good times the bad
times bad times thanks that's that is
what's coming my friends you haven't
felt the effects of that chance India
yeah like five serious new followers
that loved the way you chanted when we
champion chanting again I'm so happy
right now Charlie asks what's your
strategy when dealing with a pissed off
customer hey Charlie I've got a really
interesting answer to my thought process
I'm pissed off customers first and
foremost I want to know if they're right
and so I use myself as the judge of that
and I mean that I mean I judge how right
they are if they are 100 percent right
in my opinion I'm coming in with nothing
but empathy how do I fix it lifetime
value whatever cost me upfront right now
it doesn't matter because they're right
and in the capitalism meritocracy
fairness of the world I need to make
good on the mistake that Wine Library
vaynermedia I made and that's that now
if I think they're wrong which happens
plenty of times as well maybe 50/50 at
the time I come with offense you know I
come to explain to them that I get it
and I've empathy and I'm sorry but huge
capital beauty but you're a douchebag
and let me explain blah blah blah blah
blah blah and so that is really the way
it is so first and foremost I assess the
situation I never try to put my best
interests in mind and so if I think
they're right Lauren don't be scared and
if I don't think they're and I think
that they're right I'm gonna then just
do what I said in part one but if I
think they're wrong I'm gonna play it a
different way
Lauren was scared
mmm-hmm the rule I got ug rock added
that dick hey Gary Jason Hanson here in
the beautiful San Francisco Bay Area I'm
heading off to a networking event and
thought I'd asked you what is Gary B's
game networking what do you do love to
hear from you thanks Jason I think you
know networking is super-important to me
at this point
you know there's two different levels of
networking for me number one I'm in an
environment where I'm known right
through the last decade I've built up
some brand equity and there's a bit very
different strategy of walking into a
room where there is context around me
I'm in a wine space in a social media
space marketing space I'm gonna be able
to play in that way a little bit
different in that world I'm kind of I'm
receiving right I'm letting things come
to me this is the opportunity for a lot
of people to pitch me I want to give
them value and so in those environments
where I have context and brand and
leverage I actually give back
I actually just set up shop and I get
pitched for days bro on the other side
when I go to many places where nobody
knows who I am I'm on the offense to not
overthink it so I will never figure out
like who's the biggest dog or dog yet in
the room that I want to get to and like
I'm gonna get mines what I really do is
I come in and really go very open and
create a scenario where you know Jason
or you go walk let's go yeah don't worry
say hi to the vaynernation is there no
cutting you say there's no cutting
anymore there's no cutting you know
editing this is real this is I know it's
going alive right now right yeah just
don't like to be in Beth look look I
know you like that so I said hello be a
nice guy hi how you doing good awesome
best best accent at vaynermedia half
Boston half New York very conflicted and
so in places where I'm not known I'm I'm
really looking to to just let the
serendipity take over I think I think
networking you get very easy very
quickly right you have such a hard core
objective to me I let it come to me that
is my overall plan I by nature am a
counter-puncher from all my aggression
and bravado
and what what I project on stage because
it's a different environment in in in in
real life I'm very much let things come
to me and I like to react it's a little
more chess it's kind of like it's like I
wish I knew more about martial arts
because I feel like sometimes people
leave comments and Facebook and YouTube
well it's like it's like martial like
the other person's thing
give me the leverage to do my thing
rocky asks what's your opinion of
Nielsen ratings and how do you benchmark
traditional versus social media success
for big brands rocky this is a great
question as you can imagine this is the
world I live in I do think that all
reporting it if it's not black and white
and quantify hold on Tim is like being
weird come here look at look at are you
right like yeah good so you know
traditional metrics you know reporting
versus black and white quantifiable data
on the back end are very different you
know attribution models done on the web
the whole way where you can see the
whole funnel you can take more in that
than you can the reporting and whether
that's reporting from traditional like
TV Nielsen's or even digital reporting
like there's plenty of digital reporting
and so you got to look at them
differently and look I'm a very big
believer in branding and marketing what
I call qual data and so to me that stuff
is very important and I believe in brand
I mean I don't look at the hardcore
quant data of this show I think I'm
building brand I'm bringing value over
the last several episodes I felt a suit
uptick in my Twitter stream and the
internet comments of the shows getting
good I'm bringing you know literally in
the last week anecdotally not hardcore
data I've seen like 1314 people tweet or
Instagram about like how the more they
go into my rabbit hole of content the
more value or like he's really hitting a
stride so I can feel it it's like a
branding thing like I can feel this show
in the last show in the last show like
we're taking it up a notch a little bit
as we head into the crescendo that is
episode 100 and so I think they both
matter if I'm looking at data I'm gonna
look for something as pure as possible
and so in general digital stuff attracts
me more but I think there's a place for
both
good point oh we need to get this guy
this to the office
what's he sounds good pizza what's that
what's his name Asia all right clearly
the vaynernation is falling in love with
a shin like who cares about Gary it's
all about asian asian I got some good
news for you and I bad news my man first
of all you're adorable second ball
you should be Xander's friend third of
all if you've become Nisha's friend
she's gonna boss you around so stick
with Xander fourth of all Mike doesn't
let me eat pizza anymore so I have no
goddamn idea who's got Dan with the kid
okay
no I'm leaving it we don't edit d-roc
question of the day what is your
favorite topping on pizza and where is
the best pizza in the world
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them